records that were just revealed show
that for years
banks around the world have helped
divert and conceal criminal funds
now documents leaked from the u.s
treasury department appeared to show how
banks helped to circumvent international
sanctions
including against iran and syria
danish and british banks as well as
germany's deutsche bank
are among those implicated in leaked
files
all over the world criminals are using
the global financial system to launder
money
it's a dirty but lucrative business for
the banks
if a bank notices a suspicious transfer
it has to report it
to the authorities
thousands of such reports were obtained
by buzzfeed news
and then evaluated by the icij
it's an international network of
investigative journalists
they've discovered evidence of money
laundering worth
two trillion dollars
you can earn a lot by handling money
from criminal sources
that's why it's hard for banks to say no
to criminal money
in germany deutsche bank has some
explaining to do
the country's largest bank already had
to pay millions in fines in 2017
after dodgy dealings in russia the
investigation reveals that those illegal
activities are much more extensive
than previously thought russian
criminals used deutsche bank's moscow
branch to launder millions
the current ceo christian seving served
as head of corporate auditing
at the time he did not raise the alarm
but subsequent external investigations
did
deutsche bank says it has since
toughened its internal controls
and it denies that ceo seving did
anything wrong
it says he was unaware of the external
probe
he founded a unit that led these
investigations
they've since been is investigations too
and at no stage could any responsibility
be traced back to the head of the
business
the investigation also shows that u.s
president donald trump
may have profited from dirty money
oligarchs from kazakhstan
allegedly bought apartments at a trump
new york property with laundered money
trump's company denies knowing who these
customers were
but they did make money from the
transactions
the investigation shows the scale of
international money laundering
efforts to kerbert are floundering
because regulators can't get to grips
with highly sophisticated criminal
networks
and we have team coverage of this story
we're joined by bdw business reporter
arthur sullivan here in the studio
and we also have joining us from
frankfurt chelsea delaney welcome to
both of you arthur i'd like to begin
with you the scale of this it seems
enormous
what does it say about the financial
system yeah the scale is enormous sarah
so as the report just mentioned
two trillion dollars worth of
transactions are covered by these 18
years which detail
various financial transactions involving
some of the world's largest banks
400 journalists 16 months of extensive
research has gone into all this
what it says about the financial system
is really a lot of things so in some
respects some of this
would is not a shock we know that banks
have
to some extent facilitated money
laundering they've allowed transactions
to happen for years and many of them
have been investigated that
what this shows us though is the extent
to which that has happened a huge extent
two trillion dollars worth as i've said
now two big questions emerged from this
really i mean several questions will
emerge in the next few days but
for me at the moment two big ones emerge
it's important to remember that the
banks themselves have reported this
information the leak comes from us
authorities
which the banks provided activities
suspicious activity reports to
but the question is if banks are
wondering about these suspicious reports
if they see a transaction that they
think is suspect
why do they allow it to happen why are
they able to receive money from that
transaction
in some instances a lot of money and why
authorities not done more to stop it if
they know that this is happening
why is it continuing to happen that's
the big question those are some really
big questions um and chelsea i'd like to
turn to you and perhaps we can dig down
into one of the examples because
reportedly sixty percent of these leaked
transactions
came from deutsche bank um you're
standing by
uh close to their headquarters they're
in frankfurt just walk us through
deutsche's role
so deutsche bank is definitely finding
itself at the center of this scandal
we don't know exactly if this this
portion of leaked documents is really
representative of all
of the the suspicious activity reports
reported to the treasury or
um if if these actually lead to criminal
activity but
being involved in 60 is certainly not a
good
um a good look for deutsche bank
especially after its history
in the past several years of being
embroiled in so many
financial scandals but what this data
really shows is that
deutsche bank has had a very lack system
of controls
even the most basic controls things like
knowing who your customers are so
knowing who you're dealing with having
their addresses
having their names they they really
didn't they didn't have that for a lot
of their clients especially
in regards to business that was
happening in their moscow office so
uh that's definitely a big concern and
as well they they also
um had a lot of reports of this elevated
to the highest level so executives that
board
their board had had reports of of these
very lacks anti-money money laundering
controls
and they didn't really take action
deutsche bank is saying that they have
uh fixed a lot of this they've invested
a lot of money and they're now a new
bank
but it certainly raises a lot of
questions certainly um
how about you know on the part of
regulators i mean how could this
continue for so long
it also of course really points the
finger at regulators
the banks themselves obviously have a
lot of work to do but you know since the
financial crisis
regulators have taken a lot of action to
really get banks to clean up their act
and it's clearly not working because
many banks have been fined for uh for
activity related to money laundering and
they just continue to
uh to repeat the same actions over and
over again so clearly the the fines that
they're handing down
uh are not really deterring this kind of
behavior so
you know one one discussion today is
really should there be stronger
penalties for
uh failing on money money laundering
grounds should there be arrests should
there be
criminal prosecution because the the
fines and
sort of the the the demands that
banks stop doing this are clearly not
successful now in preventing this kind
of behavior
chelsea delaney with the view from
frankfort arthur sullivan here in the
studio
thank you so much to both of you
you